Seit 500 Jahren gibt es mitten in der
bayerischen Stadt Augsburg die Fuggerei –
die älteste Sozialsiedlung der Welt.
In den 142 Wohnungen auf zwei Stockwerken
leben heutzutage rund 150 Menschen
mit sehr geringem Einkommen.
Die Miete beträgt nur 88 Cent pro Jahr,
ein winziger Bruchteil dessen,
was eine Wohnung normalerweise in
Deutschland kostet.
Die sieben Gassen der Fuggerei sind wie ein
kleines Dorf auf rund 15.000 Quadratmetern.
Hallo! Grüß Gott!
Mein Name ist Ilona Barber, ich wohne
seit sechs Jahren hier in der Fuggerei
und ich find’s sehr, sehr schön,
hier zu wohnen,
vor allem der Zusammenhalt, den wir haben.
Wir zahlen hier nur 88 Cents [Cent]
im Jahr an Miete.
Kann man natürlich sich auch noch leisten.
Also, das ist jetzt die Küche,
die ist zwar nicht groß,
aber es – vollkommen –
reicht für mich als Einzelperson,
dort zu leben.
Meine Wohnung besonders
ist halt eben knapp 60 Quadratmeter,
was auch eigentlich relativ groß ist.
Ich bin froh und ich bin glücklich,
hier zu leben.
Und vor allem habe ich keine, sagen wir mal
jetzt, momentan keine Geldsorgen mehr.
Dass es die Fuggerei überhaupt gibt,
liegt an Jakob Fugger.
Der Kaufmann aus Augsburg
galt im 16. Jahrhundert
als der wohl reichste Mann seiner Zeit.
Er stiftete 1521 die Fuggerei
als Wohnort für Bedürftige,
und zwar auf ewig.
Alexander Erbgraf Fugger-Babenhausen
gehört in 16. Generation
zur Verwaltung der Stiftung,
die sich vorwiegend aus Einnahmen aus der
eigenen Forstwirtschaft finanziert.
Der Stifter hat in der Stiftungsurkunde
definiert, dass
unverschuldet in Not geratene
Menschen aus der Region, aus Augsburg,
hier sich als Bewohner bewerben können.
Die Liste der Bewerber ist leider länger
als die Plätze, die wir anbieten können.
Der Grundansatz,
der hier gelebt wird, ist Hilfe zur Selbsthilfe.
Also, dass die Personen,
die wir in der Fuggerei aufnehmen,
tatsächlich auch unterstützt werden,
irgendwann auch wieder
ausziehen zu können.
Im Laufe der Jahrhunderte wurde
die Fuggerei vergrößert und modernisiert,
auch nach der Zerstörung
im Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Ein kleines Museum zeigt,
wie man vor 500 Jahren in der Fuggerei lebte.
Hier sind wir jetzt in der Stube,
das ist eigentlich ein sehr großzügiger Raum
für die damalige Zeit.
Dieser Raum wurde nicht nur
als Wohnzimmer genutzt,
sondern auch als Stube,
um der Arbeit nachzukommen.
Hier waren ja auch viele Handwerker.
Das ist das Schlafzimmer oder die Kammer.
Der Raum war unbeheizt,
und wahrscheinlich hat
die ganze Familie auch
in diesem Zimmer gemeinsam geschlafen.
Man sieht, an diesem Bett,
da kann man aus der Schublade
das erweitern für die Kinder.
Der katholische Glaube ist ein Muss
in der Fuggerei.
Alle Bewohner sind seit 500 Jahren dazu
angehalten, täglich drei Gebete zu sprechen.
So wollte sich der Stifter
ewiges Seelenheil sichern.
Das wird nicht kontrolliert,
aber ich denk, dass jeder Bewohner,
wenn er Respekt hat und wenn er,
also ich mein, dankbar ist für das [dafür],
dass er hier wohnt,
dass er dann auch die Gebete für sich betet.
Bei allen Bewohnern wird die Bedürftigkeit
durch die Stiftung genau geprüft.
Es leben viele Rentner hier,
aber auch einige junge Mieter.
Hallo, ich bin ist Lisa Kron
und wohne hier seit zwei Jahren
und zeige Ihnen jetzt gerne meine Wohnung.
Die 23-Jährige hat bereits einen achtjährigen
Sohn und noch keine Berufsausbildung.
So, wir sind hier jetzt in
meinem Wohnzimmer.
Nebendran ist das Kinderzimmer,
da steht schon die Wiege,
weil in zwei Monaten
bekomme ich mein Kind.
Also, es hilft mir schon sehr, sehr viel,
weil ich hab auch ziemlich viel Unterstützung,
und wenn ich Probleme hab,
kann ich auch mit jemandem sprechen.
Auch dass viele Touristen kommen,
um die Fuggerei anzuschauen,
hilft der Stiftung finanziell:
Die Eintrittsgelder machen 20 Prozent
der Einnahmen aus.
Die Fuggerei will auch zu ihrem 500.
Geburtstag ihr Fortbestehen sichern –
vielleicht nicht für die Ewigkeit,
aber doch für die kommenden Jahrhunderte.